think back to where we started - now it's
just us - we need to end this war
this goes beyond Loyalty - this is about survival
must fight together now or die
our enemy doesn't tire
doesn't stop - they're coming
hey guys, Pete here. finally
got some more season 8 footage - short
teaser trailers came out last night at
first they were just recordings from the
TBH someone had done with their phone
but we got a couple better versions
finally right before I started recording
this video we'll look at all the scenes
here that we didn't see from the first
trailer but these are more of an
extension of what we saw than brand-new
trailers like there's not a whole lot
new here definitely follows the same
theme with a little bit of extra and
some added voiceover the first big thing
that everyone will notice I'm sure was
that we see John and Aria together in
the scene for the first time since the
first season it looks like they're by
the weirwood tree in Winterfell although
we can't see the pool so I'm not sure
exactly but there's snow on the ground
obviously John has his standard brooding
look on his face he's struggling with
something and it would appear that aria
is there to give him advice or at least
listen to him the next additional clip
that we see here is we had seen this
photo of Daenerys in the original
trailer but now we can see it looks like
Jorah is behind her we see him come out
of the shadows there we get an aerial
shot of Winterfell with drogon flying
towards it this seems to be from the
same sequence whenever they're arriving
at the castle and in both clips we saw
this shot of Tyrion Varys and Davos
looking up and to me since this is
juxtaposed with all of the footage of
the dragons flying around also the shot
of Sansa looking up it seems to me that
they are pulling a fast one on us many
people have been talking about this
since the first trailer came out because
we got this footage of drogon and
Rhaegar flying around and in different
settings that perhaps they were pulling
a fast one in that they didn't put John
on ragel and Daenerys on drogon I think
this shot here kind of really ties it up
you know that they probably are all
looking at
on a dragon seeing him for the first
time and in this first teaser of the to
the other image that we see is John in
the crypts laying a candle and it
appears to me that he is by Ned's statue
this could be the same as the first
trailer where we saw Daenerys come to
John while he's there but it's hard to
tell from the shot that we see here we
have all been sort of expecting the
crypts we'll play some part in John
coming to terms with his true parentage
but I don't think there's anything
additional here to give us context as to
what he's doing right then another shot
that was new is this one here that's
from inside the walls of Winterfell we
can see the battle is going on people
are running around on the battlements
and the first couple of shots we see
with the troops in formation with grey
worm you can tell that there's been an
actual battle going on when we see this
you see smoke you see what looks like
flames lighting up the horizon behind
the walls this looks a lot more like the
period of time where we see Brienne
Jamie and pod and Arya all fighting on
the battlements another shot of the
unsullied in formation this looks like
pre battle and that's about it as far as
new stuff in that trailer the voice-over
is broken up into different parts
it starts out by saying think back to
where we started when I first watched
that I thought this was all John this
whole part but the voice kind of cracks
on the think back to where we started
and maybe Sam's voice that we hear first
I'm not a hundred percent sure you guys
can tell me what you think about that
then we definitely hear John he says now
it's just us we need to end this war and
then we hear Jamie's voice who says this
goes beyond loyalty this is about
survival the second teaser is the one
that we hear Tyrians voice over on the
big shot and this one is Tyrion standing
in Winterfell in the Great Hall we can
see Sansa sitting at the table with
Daenerys to her side Tyrion is
addressing the
entire room we should imagine that their
other northern Lords are in the room
there as well
Tyrion just says we must fight together
now or die then we hear John again and
the voiceover he says our enemy doesn't
tire doesn't stop they're coming
another new shot here is we see De Niro
standing in front of fire
John is behind her they look to be
having a serious conversation but
there's nothing else to tell us about
what they're talking about Daenerys has
a pretty spectacular looking braid but
beyond that we can't see her face can't
see what is going on with her we get a
shot of barek with his flaming sword in
the heat of battle so we can say for
sure that he's made it to the Battle of
Winterfell I can't say for a hundred
percent but it does look like this is
him fighting with the Hound this is the
Hound silhouette and the front here it
cuts to his face in the next scene like
I said it's not a hundred percent but I
think that that is the Hound coming to
grips with his fear of fire I think
we're gonna see him do something heroic
there we have another shot of the
unsullied here that's a new one they're
in formation again this is probably
before the battle begins we see a shot
of John that's similar to what we've
seen with the other characters here he
swings Longclaw the background here
isn't glowing red like in some of the
other battle shots we see but I'm not
sure we can make any conclusions from
that there's a quick shot of Cersei
that's mixed in there that we haven't
seen yet she's wearing her crown and her
full gear it's basically just her
turning towards the camera and we can't
tell who else is in the shot with her
there's another sequence of Jon running
which we saw in the first trailer the
original trailer this is a little bit
longer I think and we do see the fire in
the background here but I don't see
anything new to give away any hints as
to what is going on in that scene
there's another cool looking shot of the
unsullied the helmets kind of in
silhouette
and then there's a longer sequence of
Aria fighting which doesn't give away
much more but it's a little bit longer
and a little bit clearer than what we
saw in the very first trailer so not a
whole lot as far as new footage I mean
they're too 30-second teasers but quite
a few frames that we didn't see in the
very first full-length trailer not much
that is surprising I didn't say it's
interesting to see Sansa and Daenerys
sitting at the table but I mean that's
pretty inevitable that that was going to
happen
Tyrion being the voice of reason
certainly the most exciting thing is
seeing John and Aria in a scene together
it's been a long time coming
still no shots of ghosts that are
confirmed in this one we don't see
Melisandre we don't see any Greyjoy's
other than the same shots of the boats
that we saw in the original trailer we
still don't see the dead here either and
I don't think that's surprising I think
they want to keep that as a big reveal
but even when we brighten up these
scenes they didn't give us much to show
us actually what's happening just that
there's a battle going on like I said
you can see the fire in the background
but keep in mind that doesn't
necessarily mean that the dragons are
involved at this point because they're
fighting whites and fire is one of the
ways that you can kill whites and from
what we understand there's going to be
bonfires and things like that so can't
really tell much as far as whether the
dragons are actually involved we do have
that same shot of drogon but beyond that
we don't see any dragon fire and we
certainly don't see the night king or
the syrian and his blue flame anywhere
but it's still pretty exciting so let me
know what you think in the comments did
you see anything that I missed anything
new that comes to mind after you saw
these teasers that you didn't think
about from the first trailer like I said
I was kind of caught up with that idea
that they may have not put John and
Danny in I mean it's CGI in the first
place it's not like they would be in the
shot until they put that together
that one shot of Santa is repeated in
all three of the trailers that we've
seen so far and that one is the one that
whenever people said she looks like
she's just seen something that really
makes you think that John's probably on
Ragle there I think now that we saw
Tyrion
Davos and Varys shot I mean it pretty
much confirmed what you say I don't know
all right well let me know what you guys
think in the comments please like the
video if you enjoyed it I got some more
problems videos coming out this week so
if you want to follow along with that
you know what to do
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon